for as long as video games have existed
Gamers have found community in the hobby
we share and those communities didn't
just form around the games fans have
also become obsessed with the characters
themselves sometimes too frightening
degrees
whether by cosplaying or creating a
custom character there are plenty of
ways for gamers to express themselves
unfortunately due to the limitations of
character creators and local craft
stores finding a character that not only
looks like you but also matches your
voice and personality is damn near
impossible
watch this
however it's not completely impossible
you see through the miracle of the stars
aligning there is a young woman who
ended up being the embodiment of the
character she was hired to play meet
Shannon Williams the X K-pop Star turned
twitch content creator who
serendipitously became the voice face
and personality of valorant's most
popular character
whoa
[__]
one enemy remaining okay is this my Ace
is this gonna be my Ace
so how did an Instagram DM take Shannon
from singing to headlining valorant how
did she build an entire Community out of
just one voice roll and who really came
first Shannon Williams or jet I would
make fun of their dumb faces but they're
us he looks stupid oh my gosh shut the
[__] up I swear to God my voice is so
annoying
but before we get into the Amazing Story
of Shannon Williams I'd like to tell you
a little bit about the sponsor for this
video Opera GX Opera GX is the browser
custom built for gamers with handy
features like twitch and Discord
integration resource limiters and even a
video game deals aggregator to save you
money Opera GX is insanely customizable
it's got tons of color schemes to match
your setup and downloadable wallpapers
too but most importantly it features a
[__] ton of extension so you can make
your browser do anything do you need to
take screenshots of specific frames of
YouTube videos because you're making a
don't at me thumbnail probably not
because you don't work with the score
Esports but trust me that is an
incredible feature do you want to block
crypto miners from jacking your PC for
their nefarious ends do you miss the
T-Rex game the only good thing about
Chrome do you want an extension that
automatically collects your channel
points on Twitch without you having to
click anything Opera GX extensions have
you covered there's even an extension
that redirects you away from all Rick
rolls you know in case you're trapped in
2008 and desperately need to save
yourself so go check out Opera GX today
using the link in the description box
below it's the browser that's custom
built for gamers but you can also custom
build it for you so at first glance
Shannon William seems like the most
stereotypical twitch streamer in the
world she loves anime dogs has pastel
colored hair and plays valorant but
before she was grinding through the
ranks blowing up on Twitch and doing IRL
Cloud bursts Shannon had a very very
different lifestyle born in England in
1998 most of Shannon's spare time as a
kid wasn't spent gaming in fact her life
was dedicated to more classy Pursuits
the other Hobbies I had when I was a kid
was like ballet learning the violin and
the piano but gaming was something that
was a small small thing that I would
have not a lot of time for
um and then due to my mom also being
like you can't you can't game too much
it's bad for you Shannon really
connected with music leading her down a
path of pursuing singing musical theater
and eventually K-pop as a career Shannon
is actually half Korean and bilingual
which landed her on several South Korean
singing shows until she was picked up by
an agency and trained to be a member of
a new in development K-Pop group five
dolls unfortunately not everything was a
dream come true for Shannon you see in
case you didn't know the world of K-pop
can be pretty toxic on top of some K-pop
stands being part of my French bash it
crazy the industry itself is absolutely
ruthless and can really grind a person
down one thing for sure was I felt like
I lost a lot of passion for singing
K-pop is very cookie cutter has to be
very perfect and the choice in what
genre I wanted to sing or like what
album I wanted to do or how many songs
like I had no creative control Shannon
released two albums and multiple singles
as she worked towards a solo career in
singing and acting But as time went on
she was growing increasingly
disillusioned by her experiences in
K-pop so towards the end of 2019 after
10 years of being in the industry
Shannon's contract with her Korean
agency finally ended and she went back
home to England for some much needed
rest or so she thought until an
Instagram DM took her on a journey she
never expected yeah I just random
Instagram DM saying hey saw you were
back in London we're actually holding
auditions here in wherever wherever
studio and right in the center of London
if you were
interested it's for a game pretty big
game company
um of course never never ever disclosed
who or what it was and I was intrigued
because you know I like I have a special
place in my heart for games because by
that time I was infatuated with
OverWatch I remember I was like so
sweaty grinding that game with all my
friends back in Korea the agent was
talking about how it was an FPS game
like it's pretty competitive and I was
really intrigued so I went in for the
audition then after several auditions
Shannon finally got more information
about what she was actually performing
for project a at this point we all know
project a was gonna become Ryan's next
big hit valorant but Shannon had no idea
what she was getting into or that the
character she was reading for was going
to become the de facto face of the game
jet like jet Shannon was Korean too but
from the moment she got a hold of the
character sheet they were even more
similarities and it started to seem a
bit Eerie it was already weird to be
quite honest it was already weird I
already had like white
I believe I had my hair up in a bun real
lazy just went into the audition and I'm
like looking at this artwork and it
looks just like me it was really creepy
to be quite honest but even more uncanny
than the similarities in their
background hairstyle and other physical
characteristics were their personal
qualities jet was independent confident
and free the exact same traits that once
helped Shannon navigate her perilous
Journey Through the music industry the
difference was that Shannon never felt
truly in control when making music but
in her Valerian auditions she didn't
just step into a role she became Jet and
ended up shaping the character along the
way there were you know bits and pieces
that I felt like I could really connect
to this feeling of having this
responsibility kind of on her shoulders
but kind of having to tough it out and
put on this facade of like I'm I'm fine
you know like I'm I'm great I'm badass
and I really really vibed with that and
I feel like they kind of wanted her to
be more timid but due to my Outlook on
on very sweaty FPS gaming I kind of
wanted to bring in this little bit of
not a nasty streak but like a very like
a lot of cockiness and
it was just great that I was able to
kind of
uh breathe life into this character with
my own interpretations and and having
that creative control so I I really
really wanted a voice there as soon as I
did like the first audition needless to
say Shannon got the part and once the
Valor and beta was released to the
public Jack quickly became a fan
favorite not just for her cocky demeanor
and [__] talking voice lines but because
on the server jet was Far and Away the
best agent in the game for those
confident in their skill
clone killed
I'm up I'm up
then three one way
I got it
done
between her unique Mobility letting her
abuse the ARP and weighs no other agent
could and her character and design
appealing to a huge demographic jet
became something of a mascot for
valorent eventually Shannon picked up
the game herself after all since she was
an actual character in valorant giving
it a try felt like a no-brainer and
despite the growing pains that come with
getting into tax Shooters Shannon
enjoyed herself thanks in part to the
community who quickly realized they were
playing with the literal IRL Jet and
welcomed her with open arms you sound
exactly like um like Jet's voice actor
yeah don't exactly like her yeah wow
what a coincidence my name's Shannon
what the [__] of course there were still
challenges twitch chat can be a
veritable Cesspool at times anyone
trying to grow their stream by playing
competitive Shooters is gonna need thick
skin luckily our IRL jet knew exactly
how to handle it and her natural ability
to talk [__] even got people on her side
who the [__] is saying this is fun is
this fun to you
this is a [__] Massacre
this is fun because you got crusty ass
Kevin carrying your ass as valorant
quickly became the hottest game on
Twitch Shannon's stream also exploded in
popularity but she wasn't doing it for
the clout you see Shannon already knew
what it was like to be famous from her
days in the Korean music industry but
twitch allowed her to make a real
connection with her fans for the first
time I always wanted to stream
um and connect with my audience because
due to reasons I wasn't actually allowed
to do a lot of that during my K-pop
career it felt like I didn't have the
opportunity to to give back to the
community that was so supportive during
that the timing was impeccable to be by
honest but Shannon's popularity couldn't
be boiled down to oh look IRL jet sure
that novelty may have gotten people to
watch a stream or two but it was
something else that got them to stick
around you see despite being a Zuma and
dabbling in gaming before Shannon was
still a bit of an outsider the closest
she ever got to attack FPS was grinding
OverWatch back in Korea with her friends
but valoran is a completely different
ball game this meant that the real draw
of Shannon's stream was watching her
learn everything about valorin The Good
the Bad and the Ugly be quiet quiet
the Wall's about to break
foreign
as for you Chad that's for you
hello
[Music]
whoa oh Bucky one more
come on
and on top of watching Shannon develop
into a degenerate gamer like the rest of
us her audience also loved that she was
already as cocky and audacious as jet so
if she couldn't back up her game with
cracked aim she could at least do it
with words [__] sorry get off my dick
what kind of question is do you think
you're bad at this game because you're a
female get the [__] out of here mate
that's hella small dick energy but
perhaps one of the biggest draws to
Shannon's stream is simple she's an
actress that worked on ballarant has
formed relationships with other voice
actors and will occasionally invite them
onto her stream and that is pure uncut
fan service the Casual valerun Community
loves these characters giving fans a
chance to hang out with them aloud
Shannon and her colleagues to maintain a
connection with the balaran community
that goes beyond just being a voice
actor behind their favorites people want
you to say jet revive me and I feel like
that would be the nice
ending note to this encounter jet revive
me
and this really is the Crux of Shannon's
story she's good at a lot of things
singing gaming and perhaps most
importantly marketing herself Shannon
could have easily just done her job and
collected a paycheck but she saw an
opportunity to turn a voice acting gig
into a following and community that she
had been yearning for
enjoy yeah yes
so the answer to who came first Shannon
or jet Almost Doesn't Matter Shannon
intentionally blurred those lines to
give everyone exactly what they wanted
Riot found the secret sauce with
valorant the agents their personalities
they built a fervor that goes beyond the
confines of a video game titles like
Apex Legends and OverWatch might have
built dedicated fandoms but valorant
took things to the next level and
although the relationship is definitely
symbiotic a lot of valorant success off
the server is exemplified by Shannon and
what she's been able to accomplish now
all this isn't to say that Shannon is
just some celebrity cashing in on
parasocial relationships as I said
before Gamers do sometimes share
similarities with K-pop stands
collectively we do suck sometimes so
Shannon being able to come in as an
outsider and build a healthy Community
even with valoran being relatively
inclusive compared to other games is
pretty impressive more importantly it's
impossible to understate just how
genuine of a person she is sure she's
self-confident but why the hell
shouldn't she be Shannon's a singer an
actor the voice behind one of the most
popular characters in Esports and she's
spent years of her life grinding to get
to a point where she can have fans she
really connects with I think we can all
agree that she's earned just a little
Cockiness you don't really come across a
lot of characters
um that openly talks so much smack all
the time and I'm like you know it's nice
to kind of be able to have this
character be so aggressively cocky and
so playful but also has the means to
back it up I feel like that's the work
ethic I've always had for me personally
too is like if I want to be able to talk
[__] or say something
um you know by all means I have to have
the credibility for it I have to have
that foundation for it and and and
that's why a lot of my personality
definitely shines through Jet and I feel
like that's that's definitely something
I'm very proud of holy I
[__] but you know what it's okay I did
10 hours of violent yesterday after
[__] six hours of work and I'm down
to play more
I originally wanted to do
ma'am my dogs are a little needy
um
[Music]
um okay what is happening why are you
all so quiet and then as soon as I start
talking I'm sorry I don't know what's
gone into them today